ومن
خلف
اضان سقوط
المنط في البرازيل فقد اقتحم محتجون قصر
[موسيقى]
الرئاسي القمه العربيه
الثانيه هذه نشاهدها لحظات هو الزلزال لا
اله الا الله زلزال تاريخي في تركيا اذا
انهيار عشرات المباني جراء الزلزال العنيف
الذي ضرب سوريا
[موسيقى]
وتركيا وتمكنت فرق الدفاع المدني من اسعاف
عدد
طري تطورات الانقلاب في النيجر حيث قال
الفيديو الاكثر متابعه في
هذا
وانفجر هذا الصاروخ بعد انطلاقه من تكساس
الهند هبط المسبار الفضائي اله تدم
الاشتباكات والمعارك في جنوب العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه في مطار الخرطوم الدولي وتشهد
كندا اسوا موسم من حرائق الغابات على
الاطلاق مع وجود
ا ركاب شرق الهند
افغانستان
لمن سيصوت الاتراك في انتخابات يتخطى
تاثيرها يفوز رجب طيب اردوغان اخيرا على
منافسه وضع التاج على راسج غامض اد
لمسو بتفجير
السد موقع تويتر ايون ماسك عن تغي كانت
حاضره في مسرح العمليات في
اوكرانيا مثيره ناجحه من عدد كبير من
الوساطات حيث اتهم رئيس مجموعه فنر وقتل
جميع من كانوا على
م الى الانهيار سريعا زلزالا بقوه سبع
درجات هز مناطق من
المغرب تعيش مدن الشرق الليبي تحت وطا من
تداعيات الاعصار دانيال واس كم عدد العدد
كم المدينه منطقه منكوبه ودعى الى تدخل
دولي ونعلن بعون الله المشهد الغير مسبوق
طوفان
الاقصى تلبيب وانفجارات قويه تسللا
لمقاومين الى مستوطن
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على حاله الحرب
احنا نايمين في امان الله عامنا منبه
ايش وصفوا ب بال
المستشفى وين ففي الشمال على الحدود
اللبنانيه كانت شكرا يا
يطش يا زلمه معلش لا سمح الله التي دمرها
الاحتلال بشكل كامل فلسطين هذه معركه لا
غبار
عليها بكف خرجت مظاهره حاشده مجاهدون
تحق ان عناصرها قتلوا من مسافه الصفر
تلفهم فناه فهم لا يبصرون اولويات تحركات
دوله قطر يسعي للوقف الفوري لاطلاق ات
حركه حماس التوصل الى اتفاق على هدنه
انسانيه
لغده
تمام الافراج عن 39 اسيرا واسيرا انتهت
هذه الدنه في يومها
السابع الان الى العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه وفاه المخ نواف الاحمد الجابر
الصباح الطائرات
المسيره روح الروح هذ روح الروح مقاطع كل
علامه ومن تدعم اطلقت زاره مجموعتها
الجديده ان قوات انصار الله الحوثيين تجبر
سفينه حاويات سيد عبد
الفتاح ينقل لنا مراسل الجزيره ان عدد
الشهداء
جراء